[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission pour ceux qui
font l'actualité du département est
aujourd'hui mercredi 21 juin parole
notamment à christophe 26 ans adjoint de
la division prévision de la région ile
de france centre pour météo france nous
évoquerons avec lui la vague de chaleur
qui dure sur la région parisienne et
nous verrons si ces fortes températures
annonce un été caniculaire parole aussi
dans cette émission à jacques blanchard
directeur général de mrm une société
d'investissement immobilier propriétaire
d'un centre du centre commercial sud
canal à montigny le bretonneux
le centre qui vient tout juste d'être
rénovée et qui espère ainsi profiter
d'une nouvelle dynamique commerciale
nous en reparlerons avec vous christophe
vincent bonsoir je le disais vous êtes
désormais adjoint de la division
prévision de la région ile de france et
centre pour météo france
en ce moment on parle énormément de la
météo aujourd'hui encore il a fait plus
de 35 degrés dans les yvelines
météo-france d'ailleurs maintien à sa sa
vigilance orange canicule pour la région
franciliens notamment demain jeudi déjà
peut-être un point sur la météo il fera
aussi chose que vous avez des
informations la loire puisque c'est
parti pour durer
alors en ce moment à l'épisode de chute
de canicule que nous connaissons bas
depuis tous les bus de la semaine de
cette semaine
koné son pic aujourd'hui avec les plus
fortes températures mondiales
enregistrées et les plus je dirais les
plus hautes températures minimales que
nous enregistrerons ce soir dans cette
fête de la musique et on amorce un
changement gira à partir de demain on va
perdre quelques petits degrés qui ont
commencé à faire du bien ça reste
important élevé voilà ça reste encore
élevé et le changement va être plus
marquées vendredi avec en fait qu'un
un changement des vents un retour de
notre héros de notre bien bonne vieille
circulation d'ouest way est un peu plus
d'air frais qui va nous arriver de
l'atlantique qui va nous faire perdre
encore 4,5 degrés comme ça pour le
ramener à des températures beaucoup plus
proches des normales
là par exemple nous sommes aux alentours
de 35 degrés à 21 juin il devrait faire
combien de degrés normalement s'il ya
peu près à 13 12 13 degrés aujourd'hui
au dessus des normales nous devait
autour de 22 à 23 degrés ce qui arrive
relations entre c'est exceptionnel où
finalement ça arrive assez souvent ça
arrive quelques toutous tous les 4-5 ans
ou alors c c'est quand même exceptionnel
comme phénomène les record que nous
avons enregistrée de températures
maximales doivent dater de 2011
donc ce n'est pas si exceptionnel que ça
ça revient régulièrement c'est vrai que
c'est un épisode de canicule assez
étendu puisque 63 60 sont entre 60 et 70
départements sont encore en vigilance
orange on à 67 je crois 67 visiter entre
66 et raison voilà et il a assez précoce
pour la saison alors que l'année
dernière avait marqué à part
pratiquement un seul épisode un peu
marqué qui était pas arrivé après le 15
août
petite question petite précision sur sur
la météo quand on voit les températures
s'afficher sur les cartes on a tous
regardé la météo au moins une fois dans
sa vie on voit des températures qui
s'affiche là notamment 35 degrés pour la
région parisienne
ça c'est à l'ombre ce qui veut dire que
ray au soleil combien fait-il
concrètement il fait plus de 40 degrés
aujourd'hui 40 degrés au soleil
c'est ça va dépendre de sa position sur
céréales ont besoin au soleil en fait
c'est températures sont mesurés à deux
mètres au dessus du sol
royer pan d analyser pour normaliser la
valeur de la température un seul gazonné
à l'intérieur d'un abri ventilé blanc
pour éviter tout effet de surchauffe
justement du soleil au niveau des sondes
c'est une mesure normaliser au niveau
mondial il ya une explication
particulière assez important de chaleur
du moment où alors vous le disais c'est
finalement un phénomène classique qui
peut arriver tous les 4-5 ans on connaît
toujours des épisodes des pics de
chaleur je dirais qu'on maintenant on a
affaire à quelques épisodes qui rentrent
plus qu'on appelle plus des périodes
caniculaires puisqu'elles vont rentrer
plus dans la durée ce qui va faire que
les organismes sont beaucoup moins
habitués à supporter la chaleur pendant
longtemps et surtout des nuits qui se
rafraîchissent beaucoup moins donc
beaucoup moins de repos pour le corps et
c'est vrai qu'avec notre réchauffement
climatique
on peut on peut dire aujourd'hui que du
fait du réchauffement climatique on aura
plus souvent on n'a rien vu souvent des
périodes et des périodes de fortes
chaleurs qui dureront qui vont
s'installer pendant l'été on veut pas
mettre derrière que précisément celle ci
est liée au réchauffement climatique
sans bras éventuellement le voir plus
tard mais pas aujourd'hui c'est plus
leur nombre et leur répétition qui
feront qu elles seront qu elles
marqueront là-bas j'irai laquelle seront
la marque de ce changement climatique
alors question que tout le monde se pose
aujourd'hui s'il fait 35 degrés le 21
juin il fera combien le
le 15 août il fera 45° est ce que vous
savez sur n'aura été malheureusement non
or actuellement on est les premiers
salle des c'est vrai que les premiers
résultats de la prévision saisonnière
qui sont données pour cet été qui sont
la comparaison de différents modèles en
fait d'une technique de probabilité qui
va faire qu'on va faire essayer de
converger les problèmes qui vont nous
donner quelques tendances pour cet été
nous donne des moyennes de températures
qui ont une chance sur deux je dirais ce
qui est quand même déjà assez important
pour être au dessus de la normale d'un
était classique un essai roland à
l'échelle de l'europe en moyenne sur
trois mois
d'accord c'est combien était classique
en moyenne en europe par exemple j'ai
pas la valeur je suis pas la valeur de
renom ceci quand on prend toute l'europe
falloir mener driss et que la
température j'avoue que j'ai pas le
chiffre en tête mais j'irai un été par
avoir un bel été et classique marois est
à quelques degrés au dessus qui va ça va
être favorable à l'établissement si ça
se produit réellement à des périodes de
canicule mais alain vers ce n'est pas
parce qu'on va vous donner une prévision
une tendance sur trois mois d'un été
plutôt froid qu'on n'aura pas à
l'intérieur de cet été mais je dirais
deux mois et demi complètement loupé
raté bien sûr et quinze jours qui
pourrait ressembler à 2003 j'allais vous
poser la question et ma dernière
question est ce qu'on peut écarter le
scénario de 2003 on se rappelle de
l'épisode caniculaire qui avait causé
beaucoup de morts des milliers de morts
à l'époque on l on à part on n'a pas
connu depuis 2003 un épisode semblable
mais il n'est pas écarté
merci il n'est pas écartée d'un point de
vue météorologique
d'un point de vue et fait qu'il a pu à
bord en 2003 des mesures ont été prises
ça arrive au niveau étatique et des
plans sont en route pour justement
éviter que je parlais bien sûr vu que
vous êtes un spécialiste de la gestion
de en termes de en termes de chaleur
merci christophe vincent pour toutes ces
précisions et pour plus d'information
vous pouvez aussi appeler une plateforme
spéciale qui s'est mise en place en cas
de difficulté par le ministère de la
santé au 0 800 06 66 66 merci beaucoup
de votre venue au poursuit cette
émission avec un autre a invité jacques
blanchard bonsoir bonsoir monsieur cri
le bit
alors petit rang cision peut-être avec
ce qui vient d'être dit vous êtes le
directeur général de
mrm ça c'est pour la précision une
société d'investissement immobilier
propriétaire notamment du centre
commercial sud canal à montigny le
bretonneux
est ce que pour vous les grandes
chaleurs la canicule c'est mauvais entre
guillemets pour le business je peux me
permettre cette expression est ce que
les gens vont moins dans les espaces
commerciaux du fait de la chaleur ou au
contraire parce qu'il fait plus frais on
y va on y va un peu plus alors ça ça
dépend des secteurs d'activité
évidemment les commerces de alimentaire
constate par exemple que bidamant il y
avait des bandes plus forte dans les
boissons dans l'est dans les glaces est
également discuté hier avec un de
locataires as-tu de canal quand il fait
très chaud poulets pour les meilleurs
alimentaire les gens ont tendance à
venir plutôt en fin de journée quand ils
espèrent que la température baisse un
petit peu mais les fortes chaleurs ne
sont pas effectivement un bon contexte
pour le commerce
alors vous êtes en plâtre pour évoquer
les travaux de rénovation qui sont
désormais achevés au centre commercial
sud canal de montigny le bretonneux
encore on consistaient ces travaux
qu'est ce qui a changé concrètement sur
place on envoie quelques images
peut-être des nouveaux plafonds des
nouveaux des nouvelles pancartes pour
indiquer les enseignes alors il ya eu
deux mêmes 3,3 secteur de concernant ces
travaux d'une part et c'était le point
de départ nous avons restructuré c'est à
dire diviser une surface de 5000 m² dans
la partie sur la place etienne marcel
qui était plus tellement occupé par
l'ancienne bric aura rien on se rappelle
il ya eu des travaux importants pour
subdivisée en 6 cellules
cette grande surface et donc des travaux
à ses conséquences au plan son plan
technique ça c'est là c'est là c'est la
première le premier volet ça nous a
permis donc d'accueillir de nouvelles
enseignes
1 l'enseigne actions lancées le jouet
club l'enseigne de salles de sport
fitness park
et ensuite suivi par l'antenne d'optique
jrc optique et c'était pas le zaïm
oubliée c'est bon de diviser comme ça on
va dire une grande surface ont plusieurs
surfaces c'est mieux d'avoir plusieurs
petits commerces entre guillemets même
si vous avez cité des grandes enseignes
que une énorme structure qui pourrait
englober un peu et avalé le reste des le
reste des commerces alors c'est mieux
parce que ça enrichit l'offre
au lieu d'avoir 1 1 une locomotive qui
va être mono activité est bien le fait
d'avoir accueillir c'est effectivement
pas que des petites boutiques à biskra
et les mails à jouer cloaked la salle de
sport fitness park ce sont des grandes
surfaces action également mais voilà ça
enrichit l'offre et à partir de ça on a
effectivement décidé d'amplifier ce
mouvement de renouveau par des travaux
de rénovation donc le deuxième volet ça
a été la rénovation des parcs de
stationnement le centre commercial
essaya de ses atouts dispose de deux
parcs de stationnement le parking
etienne marcel de 2 350 places qui est
sous la halle
et puis le parking vauban qui échoue
lino le djia de près de 200 places et
nous avons intégralement rénovés c'est à
dire pas changer l'éclairage moderniser
l'équipement de même les équipant de
paiement voilà pour que ça soit
confortable pour le confort et l'accueil
des clients est ce que est ce que vous
avez aussi fait ses travaux parce que la
zone commerciale connaissait quelques
difficultés et notamment depuis le
départ de bricorama est ce que ça rentre
dans ce schéma là et ce constat là alors
je réponds c'est juste et à mener pour
troisième banquette important et ça
répondra partiellement également
d'autres questions
nous avons aussi fait des travaux de
rénovation de ce qu'on appelle
l'identité visuelle 1 c'est-à-dire
changer moderniser le logo est installé
des enseignes drapeau rénover les halls
on voit ça d'accès voilà pour qu' il ya
un élément de fectivement son plan
esthétique il ya un élément de renouveau
et il est important en effet de
régulièrement de d'apporter des éléments
de modernité et de nouveautés par le
design par les coloris pour accompagner
ce qui calme le coeur de la zone
commerciale c'est à dire l'offre l'offre
commerciale et donc les enseignes qui la
composent on pourrait presque parler
d'un nouveau départ aujourd'hui selon
vous pour cette zone commerciale ou
alors c'est exagéré c'est un exercice
que c'est un petit plus parce que le
centre le centre commercial du canal est
vraiment un pôle incontournable dans
l'agglomération est connu et pérenne
certains commerçants sont là depuis plus
de vingt ans par exemple lancé une place
en 1 qui fait ac a fêté cette année ses
20 ans l'enseigne de librairies pavés du
canal bien connue même si j'ai dû bruges
qui est là depuis l'ouverture de ce
canal à la fin des années 80 donc on
peut se targuer marine a laissé un
nouvel élan c'est un nouvel élan dindar
question rapidement pour conclure cet
entretien sur votre rapport peut-être à
l'espace saint quentin comment comment
vous envisagez cc rapport aujourd'hui
vous êtes concurrents complémentaires
comment vous pourriez définir ça alors
on est complémentaires est l'un des
éléments de complémentarité il est
illustré par le groupe carrefour qui a à
la fois à ce canal l'ancien carrefour
market qui a remplacé l'ancien dia
effectivement c'est également un élément
très positif pour l'évolution du centre
on avait une enseigne dia qui était
forcément sur le déclin et bien le goût
de carrefour a décidé de garder ce point
de vente de moderniser et de le passer à
l'enseigné carrefour market est par
ailleurs bien sûr vous savez le groupe
carrefour à son hypermarché dans
l'espace saint quentin donc on voit bien
qu'on a une complémentarité et le pôle
sud canal il a à cet atout de praticité
on y accède facilement les parkings sont
plus simples et plus faciles d'accès
peut-être que les grand parking de
l'espace saint quentin il ya sept de
composants de commerce de bouche qui
fait qu' on est complémentaire avec
l'espace saint quentin et toute la
révolution qu'on sent qu'elle on
travaille c'est que les le cheminement
des piétons entre la partie face à l'ire
des lecteurs est contente traversé le
canal traverse le sud est a jusqu'à
la place etienne marseille lille bout
d'un moment je dois vous couper parce qu
on est désormais pris par le temps merci
jacques blanchard d'être venu en plateau
merci pour vos réponses rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur général de mrm
propriétaire du centre commercial sud
canal à montigny le bretonneux merci à
vous d'être venu merci de nous avoir
reçus
c'est la fin de ce cette fuite les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain d'ici là bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]